l'un des quartiers les plus pauvres et les plus mal desservis de San Francisco.
Avant tout cela,
il n'y avait eu qu'un seul pédiatre dans tout Bayview
pour soigner plus de 10 000 enfants,
nous avons lancé notre clinique et avons pu fournir des soins d'excellente qualité
même si les gens ne pouvaient pas payer.
C'était super. Nous avons ciblé des inégalités de santé typiques :
l'accès a soin, les taux de vaccination, les taux d'hospitalisation pour asthme,
et les chiffres ont explosé.
Nous étions très fiers de nous.
Mais j'ai ensuite remarqué une tendance dérangeante.
Beaucoup d'enfants m'étaient envoyés pour THDA,
ou Trouble d'Hyperactivité avec Déficit de l'Attention,
mais en faisant un examen médical complet ou en regardant les antécédents médicaux,
il s'avérait que, pour la majorité de mes patients,
je ne pouvais pas établr un diagnostic de THDA.
La plupart des enfants que je voyais avaient vécu un traumatisme si grave
que j'avais l'impression qu'il y avait quelque chose d'autre.
D'une façon ou d'une autre, je passais à côté de quelque chose.
Avant de faire mon internat, j'ai eu un master en santé publique,
et une des choses qu'ils vous enseignent en école de santé publique
est que si vous êtes médecin
et voyez 100 enfants qui boivent au même puits
et que 98 d'entre eux ont la diarrhée,
vous pouvez y aller et écrire la même prescription
pour des antibiotiques encore et encore,
ou vous pouvez demander ce qui ne va pas avec le puits.
J'ai commencé à lire tout ce que j'ai pu trouver
sur comment l'exposition à l'adversité
affecte le développement du cerveau et du corps des enfants.
Et puis un jour, un collègue est venu dans mon bureau,
et a dit : « Docteur Burke, avez-vous vu ceci ? »
Il avait dans la main une copie d'une étude
appelée l'Etude des Expériences d'Adversité de l'Enfance.
Ce jour a changé ma pratique médicale et finalement ma carrière.
Tout le monde devrait connaitre
l'Etude des Expériences d'Adversité de l'Enfance.
Elle a été menée par Dr. Vince Felitti du kaiser et Dr. Bob Anda du CDC.
Ensemble, ils ont demandé à 17 500 adultes leur historique d'exposition
à ce qu'ils appelaient les « expériences d'adversité de l'enfance » ou EAE.
Elles comprenaient les abus physiques, émotionnels ou sexuels ;
la négligence physique ou émotionnelle ;
la maladie mentale d'un parent, sa dépendance ou son incarcération ;
la séparation parentale ou le divorce ;
ou la violence domestique.
Pour chaque oui, vous obtiendriez un point sur votre score d'EAE.
Ensuite,
ils ont mis en corrélation ces scores d'EAE et l'état de santé.
Ce qu'ils ont trouvé était frappant.
Deux choses :
La première est que les EAE sont incroyablement communes.
67% de la population avait vécu au moins une EAE,
et 12,6%, une personne sur huit, avait vécu quatre ou plus EAE.
La seconde chose qu'ils ont remarquée
est qu'il y avait une relation dose-réponse
entre les EAE et les états de santé :
plus votre score d'EAE était élevé, pire était votre état de santé.
Pour une personne avec un score d'EAE de quatre ou plus,
leur risque relatif de maladie chronique d'obstruction pulmonaire
était 2,5 fois plus élevée que pour quelqu'un avec un score d'EAE de 0.
Pour les hépatites, c'était également 2,5 fois plus élevé.
Pour la dépression, c'était 4,5 fois plus élevé.
Pour les tendances suicidaires, c'était multiplié par 12.
Une personne avec un score d'EAE de 7 ou plus
avait 3 fois plus de risques d'avoir un cancer du poumon
et 3,5 fois plus de risques d'avoir une cardiopathie ischémique,
la première cause de décès aux États-Unis d'Amérique.
Bien-sûr, cela semble logique.
Certaines personnes ont regardé ces données et dit : « Voyons.
Vous avez une enfance difficile, vous êtes plus susceptible de boire ou fumer
et de faire toutes ces choses qui vont vous ruiner la santé.
Ce n'est pas de la science. C'est simplement un mauvais comportement. »
Il s'avère que c'est à ce point exactement que la science intervient.
Nous comprenons maintenant bien mieux qu'avant
comment l'exposition précoce à l'adversité
affecte le cerveau et le corps en développement des enfants.
Cela affecte des aires comme le noyau accumbens,
le centre du plaisir et de la récompense du cerveau
qui est impliqué dans la dépendance à une substance.
Cela inhibe le cortex préfrontal;
qui est nécessaire pour le contrôle de ses impulsions et la fonction exécutive,
une zone critique pour l'apprentissage.
Et sur des IRM,
on voit une différence mesurable dans l'amygdale,
le centre de réponse à la peur du cervau.
Il y a donc des raisons neurologiques
expliquant pourquoi des personnes exposées fortement à l'adversité
sont plus susceptibles d'avoir un comportement à risques,
et il est important de le savoir.
Mais il s'avère que même si vous n'avez pas de comportement à risque,
vous êtes aussi plus susceptible de développer une maladie du cœur, un cancer.
Cela a à voir avec l'axe hypothalamique - pituitaire - surrénal,
le système de réponse au stress du cerveau et du corps
qui gouverne notre réaction de la lutte ou de la fuite.
Comment cela fonctionne-t-il ?
Imaginez que vous marchez dans la forêt et que vous voyez un ours.
Immédiatement, votre hypothalamus envoie un signal à votre hypophyse,
qui envoie un signal à votre glande surrénale qui dit :
« Libérez les hormones de stress ! Adrénaline ! Cortisol ! »
Votre cœur s'accélère,
vos pupilles se dilatent, vos voies respiratoires s'ouvrent,
et vous êtes prêt soit à combattre cet ours soit à le fuir.
Et c'est génial
si vous êtes dans une forêt et qu'il y a un ours.
(Rires)
Mais le problème est : que se passe-t-il si l'ours rentre tous les soirs,
et que ce système est activé encore et encore et encore,
et qu'il passe d'évolutif, ou salvateur,
à mal adapté ou nuisible à la santé ?
Les enfants sont particulièrement sensibles à cette activation réptée
de situation de stress puisque leurs cerveau et corps se développent.
Une forte adversité n'affecte pas seulement la structure, le fonctionnement
du cerveau mais aussi le système immunitaire en développement,
les systèmes hormonaux en développement,
et même la façon dont notre ADN est lu et transcrit.
Cette information a jeté par la fenêtre mon ancienne formation,
parce que quand on comprend le mécanisme d'une maladie,
quand on connait non seulement quels chemins sont perturbés mais aussi comment,
alors, en tant que médecins, c'est notre travail d'utiliser cette science
pour la prévention et le traitement.
C'est ce que nous faisons.
A San Francisco, nous avons créé le Centre pour le Bien-être des Jeunes
pour prévenir, dépister et guérir les impacts des EAE et du stress nocif.
Nous avons simplement commencé par un dépistage systématique de nos enfants
lors de leurs examens médicaux
parce que je sais que si une patiente a un score d'EAE de 4,
elle a 2,5 fois plus de risques de développer une hépatite ou une MPOC,
elle 4,5 fois plus de risques de devenir dépressive,
et elle a 12 fois plus de risques de faire une tentative de suicide
que mes patients avec un score d'EAE de 0.
J'en ai conscience quand elle est dans ma salle d'examen.
Pour nos patients qui ont un dépistage positif,
nous avons une équipe de traitement pluridisciplinaire qui travaille
pour diminuer l'adversité et traiter les symptômes avec les meilleures pratiques
incluant les visites à la maison, la coordination des soins,
des soins psychologiques, de la nutrition,
un intervention holistique et, si besoin, des médicaments.
Nous éduquons aussi les parents sur les impacts des EAE et du stress nocif
de la même façon que pour couvrir les prises électriques
ou pour l'empoisonnement au plomb,
et nous adaptons les soins de nos asthmatiques et diabétiques
d'une manière qui reconnait leur besoin d'un traitement plus agressif
selon les changements dans leurs systèmes hormonaux et immunitaires.
L'autre chose qui se passe quand vous comprenez cette science
c'est que vous voulez le crier sur les toits,
parce que ce n'est pas un problème uniquement pour les enfants de Bayview.
J'estime qu'au moment où tout le monde en entendra parler, il y aura
un dépistage régulier, des équipes de traitement multidisciplinaires,
et ce serait la course pour avoir
les protocoles de traitement cliniques les plus efficaces.
Ça n'est pas arrivé.
Et cela a été un énorme apprentissage pour moi.
Ce que je pensais comme étant la meilleure pratique médicale
était en fait un mouvement.
Avec les mots du Dr. Robert Block,
l'ancien prédisent de l'Académie Américaine des Pédiatres :
« Les expériences d'adversité de l'enfance
représentent le plus grand menace de santé publique à laquelle
notre nation fait face et qui est négligée. »
Et pour beaucoup de monde, c'est une perspective terrifiante.
La portée et l'envergure du problème semblent si étendus que lorsque l'on pense
à comment aborder le problème, on se sent dépassé.
Mais pour moi, c'est là que réside l'espoir,
car lorsque nous avons le bon cadre
et reconnaissons cela comme une crise de santé publique,
nous pouvons alors utiliser les bons outils pour trouver des solutions.
Du tabac à l'empoisonnement au plomb au SIDA/VIH,
les Etats-Unis ont de forts antécédents
quant ils s'agit de traiter des problèmes de santé publique,
mais répéter ces succès avec les EAE et le stress nocif
va nécessiter de la détermination et de l'implication,
et quand je considère la réaction qu'a eu notre nation jusqu'ici,
je me demande :
pourquoi n'avons-nous pas pris cela plus au sérieux ?
Au début je pensais que nous marginalisions le problème
parce qu'il ne nous concernait pas.
C'est un problème pour ces enfants dans ces quartiers.
Ce qui est bizarre, parce que les données n'étayent pas cette version des faits.
L'étude initiale sur les EAE a été faite dans une population
qui était caucasienne à 70%,
dont 70% avaient fait des études.
Mais, plus je parlais aux gens,
plus je commençais à penser que j'avais peut-être tout compris de travers.
Si je demandais combien de personnes dans cette pièce
ont grandi avec un membre de la famille souffrant de maladie mentale,
je parie que quelques mains se lèveraient.
Et si je demandais combien de personnes avaient un parent qui buvait trop,
ou qui pensaient vraiment que qui aime bien, châtie bien,
je parie qu'un peu plus de mains se lèveraient.
Même dans cette pièce, c'est un problème qui touche nombre d'entre nous,
et je commence à croire que nous marginalisons le problème
parce qu'il nous concerne.
Peut-être est-ce plus facile de voir d'autres codes postaux,
parce que nous ne voulons pas voir que cela nous concerne.
Nous préfèrerions être malade.
Heureusement, les avancées scientifiques, et, franchement, les réalités économiques,
rendent cette option moins viable chaque jour.
La science est claire :
l'adversité précoce affecte dramatiquement la santé tout au long de la vie.
Aujourd'hui, nous commençons à comprendre comment interrompre la progression
de l'adversité précoce vers la maladie et la mort précoce,
et dans 30 ans,
l'enfant qui aura un score d'EAE élevé
et dont les symptômes comportementaux ne seront pas reconnus,
dont la gestion de l'asthme ne sera pas liée,
et qui développera une forte tension
et une maladie cardiaque ou un cancer précoce
sera tout aussi anormale qu'une mortalité à 6 mois causée par le VIH/SIDA/
Les gens regarderont la situation et diront : « Que s'est-il passé ? »
C'est traitable.
C'est guérissable.
La chose la plus importante dont nous avons besoin aujourd'hui
est le courage de regarder le problème en face et de dire :
c'est réel et c'est chacun d'entre nous.
Je pense que nous sommes le mouvement.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)